歡迎收看Smart投資教室,哈囉大家好,我是重薇。
財政部剛剛公佈了最新的8月進出口統計,
出口延續強勁,年增率高達41%,夠猛了吧?
可是你知道嗎,同樣是靠著出口吃飯的韓國,
8月出口年增率是多少呢?
答案是68.7%。
大家來看一下這張圖,我打賭你看完之後會忍不住哇一聲。
藍色的這個柱子是韓國每個月的出口總額
那條上下起伏的黑線則是出口的年增率
從2000年算起20多年來
這個柱子大多在中間這一帶來回
黑線也是有高有低起起落落
但是如果你把視線移到最右邊
紅框圈住的這一段
柱子則是一根接一根往上疊
直接頂到了20多年來的天花板
那黑線更誇張了
幾乎是直接噴出去
沒錯就是這麼狂
把它推上去的
就是這波AI浪潮
硬生生把韓國的出口動能
拉抬到了前所未見的新高度
出口的動能這麼的旺盛
企業當然是賺寶寶
投資圈的預估
韓國企業在2027年
他們的營業利益會正式站穩
1000兆韓環大關
其中三星電子SK海力士
這兩家的記憶提倡
擠進了全球最會賺錢的
十大企業榜單當中
我們甚至可以說
三星的獲利能力
已經跟輝達是同等級的
大家或許會想問說
這個記憶體為什麼這麼搶手
關鍵就在於AI運算的瓶頸
已經從算力轉移到了傳輸
一臺AI伺服器裡面
GPU真正拿來計算的時間
其實只佔了一到三成
剩下大多都是耗在資料的搬運上面
所以卡關的是平寬還有存儲而不是算力
這樣一來
記憶體在裝置裡面的分量就越來越吃重了
一句話總結
它已經從配角升級成了AI時代的主角
更重要的是
這波記憶體行情不是曇花一現
因為現在大廠學乖了
改採長期價格協定
接多少的單才會擴多少的產能
不會再重演過去那種殺價競爭
所以記憶體的景氣循環
從過去的兩到三年拉長到了三到五年
那麼實際問到的投資專家也說
記憶體的行情2027年肯定是更好的
2028也差不了太多
獲利能見度都已經拉這麼長了
但是大家看一下這張圖
藍線是COSIP50預估互利年增幅
從2025年以來到今年8月底
預估是427%
可是紅線的股價累積漲幅才266%
藍線一路的往上噴
紅線的漲勢卻是遠遠跟不上
所以說現在的韓股估值
真的是有點委屈了
簡單總結一下
韓國的出口動能大增
企業獲利噴發
記憶體的景氣循環又被拉長
基本面可以說是又猛又長
偏偏它的估值到現在
還被市場給低估
一邊是實力很紮實
一邊是評價不高
大家可以很清楚的看到
投資機會就藏在這個落差裡面
市場資金
接下來會不會大舉的進駐呢
就讓我們拭目以待
Smart投資教室
我們下次見
申告前音響月公開說明書